more explosions have been reported in
Ukraine's Capital Kiev and the areas
surrounding it at least three people
have been killed including two children
keeps mayor says that air defenses in
the city have been activated following
Russian air strikes he's urged people to
stay in shelters doctors say more than a
dozen people have been injured
meanwhile the U.S has announced a new
300 million dollar military aid package
to Ukraine in response to the latest
wave of missile attacks by Moscow the
assistance includes air defense systems
and ammunition
I think this week as you all seen Russia
has continued to wage just a brutal
completely unprovoked war against
Ukraine launching yet more airstrikes
and bombarding a Ukrainian cities all
across the country in fact in just this
this year month of May
Russia's launched 17 different air
assaults against Kiev
harming civilians devastating civilian
areas hitting civilian infrastructure
now in response the United States is
going to continue to support Ukraine
help give them things that they need to
better defend themselves
earlier Russia said it was evacuating
hundreds of children from villages in
the region of Belgrade very close to the
Ukrainian border the Kremlin says the
situation there is alarming the governor
of the region so as the first 300
children will be relocated to areas
further inside Russia that follows an
increase in attacks on Russian soil in
recent weeks
at least five people have been killed
and 19 others wounded by shelling in the
russian-controlled region level hansk
Moscow says Ukraine is responsible for
the attacks a construction site and a
farm were targeted Union has more on the
strikes and shelling in Russia and
Russian occupied areas of Ukraine
the belga road region that borders
Ukraine came under Fire again of four
people were injured one of them is in
the critical condition right now the
authorities of the lugansk region that
Russia considers its territory high mass
rocket filled with shrub now claimed the
lives of five people another 20 were
injured in the village of karpati in the
lugansk region according to the Russian
side and the Russian authorities and
Russian sources the Ukrainian
nationalists that's how they call them
attacked
some road equipment and houses of
civilians and one of those civilians was
killed Wednesday morning also brought
yet another drone attacker in in the
krasnada region and the afibsky oil
refinery that was targeted various
telegram channels reported it was
Ukrainian drone but officially that
hasn't been confirmed yet